we give a very brief introduction to
autism I want to say a little bit
itself what dentists can do in the
office to help folks and also to say a
little bit about some of the special
issues that autism poses for oral
healthcare and then that'll be the
transition to dr. poeple so what is
autism autism is first and foremost of
disorder that involves social
interaction as exemplified by the movie
Rain Man which is a wonderful portrayal
of what autism it's a hidden disability
and that people don't look different but
because they have major problems in
social interaction and they also have
problems in dealing with the environment
this causes causes them some issues
we're learning and we'll talk more about
that in just a second people with autism
have many strengths and they also have
some areas typically of weakness so
what's so confusing about autism well
firstly there's a tremendous range of
functioning there are people who don't
talk at all and there are people who
talk too much there are also people who
sometimes have unusual abilities that
might be 1 in 10 or so people with
autism might have some unusual ability
probably the most important thing to
know is when you met one person with
autism you've met one person with autism
because there's such a tremendous range
and someone so much variability what is
true about autism that cuts across
people the troubles with social
interaction first and foremost the most
important thing and that colours a lot
of how the person interacts with others
but also with the world and also these
are interestingly enough folks who often
have trouble with change in the
environment with violation of routine
and new things and this poses some
challenges for going to the dentist I
mentioned so so-called unusual abilities
or sometimes called savant skills of
autism this is not one this is a boy I
think about eight years the way asked to
draw himself and what he do he traces
his hand on the other hand this is a
girl three and a half Nadja who has this
wonderful drawing of a rooster and a
hint she actually lost her ability as
she got older let me say one word about
Asperger's it's a disorder related to
autism there are mark social
difficulties but good language and
cognitive skills language skills the
sense of talking a lot about something
often a topic of special interest these
topics can be all-consuming I was
mentioning to someone yesterday I was in
DC during one of the snowstorms and I
had a
patient who texted me not to get on the
red line because he follows all the
subways and he was exactly right about
one minute after I got on the red line
it stopped because of a disabled train
on the track and that's one of his
things people the Asperger's often seem
kind of quirky and they're quite verbal
but they also have major problems in
social interaction some basic
information autism is a strongly genetic
brain based disorder there are high
rates of epilepsy associated with some
genetic conditions like fragile X and
tuber sclerosis and there's an increased
recurrence risk in siblings over the
past thirty years the good news is that
early detection and earlier treatment
have led to better outcome we now have
many people going to college that being
said not everyone improves and we still
have a significant number of adults who
are especially challenged for oral
healthcare who'd basically need 24/7
residential care even for the most
cognitively able the opportunity for
supports persists and they often have
special needs around issues of anxiety
and depression and may still have some
of the troubles tolerating change the
social difficulties are the
characteristic that defines the
condition they probably delete too much
of the related cognitive disability and
also problems in the real world
generalization or adaptive skills social
abilities change over time often with
children moving from being more aloof
and kind of avoiding social interaction
to more passively accepting it and
finally becoming something that
colleague England we're in a wing called
actividad the person was in your face
talking about deep fat fryers there are
lots of difficulties including
difficulties of mutual gaze joint
attention pragmatics or the social use
of language implied meaning
idiosyncratic language figurative
language and theory of mind basically
putting yourself in the other person's
place put it another way if you come
into the world like most of us do with a
social frame many things happen if this
is your starting point for viewing the
world people are at the center of your
universe you have you engage in joint
attention you have a remarkable interest
in other people's feelings their
emotions you have a desire to
communicate because that becomes so
efficient in getting information back
and forth people starting with the
parents become the most important things
in the world
and that's what you take your cue from
if you don't have the social frame what
happens you have interest in the non
social world and I mentioned people if
you lack the social frame you get
interested in things like contingency
this little file all these little balls
rolling around what's causing all this
so the person might be interested in
fans or lights which is things that move
things that turn on and off doors that
open and close but people are looking
for meaning but through Plan B that's
where the people but looking for
relationships in the world some of the
research we've been involved in here
suggests that people with autism
probably miss about 90% of the social
effect of information at times the
failures in social orientation mean you
see me seek meaning through the
environment you look for consistency and
stability you also look for contingency
you tend to learn things as a whole
package this is called a gestalt
learning style you don't break things
down into little parts you have a whole
picture of viewing the world you have
difficulties in most two tasking and
often problems in communication so
practical issues and what can you do
about it
if you have major problems with the
direction and change you make things
familiar I think you hear a lot about
this from dr. poeple stories pictures
applications can help people understand
and predict what happened before what's
going to happen next what's going to
happen after that also going slowly
patience pays off taking things one step
at a time and not moving too quickly
also getting to know the individual
people with autism like the rest of us
as they get older they want to have
relationships they need to figure out
how to do it often in unusual ways but
you can take advantage of this because
you people desire to have relationships
and friendships if you have major
problems with organization and
flexibility again make things familiar
your stories pictures apps make things
predictable first we're going to do
lists then we're going to do this we go
to this have a schedule against going
slow family involvement is very helpful
if you have siblings who can model
behaviors and strategic retreat Riis
things like thinking about putting the
person early in the day or in the first
afternoon slot or having a special
waiting area where they can very quickly
and quietly spend time if he had
problems with sequencing attention
auditory processing again use visuals
plenty of
consistency keep your language simple
and concrete sometimes when a person is
losing it we get very respectful in our
language we start to use the subjunctive
would you could you might you
should--you wrong way to go stop that
do this keep language simple and to the
point also support attention if you have
trouble lacking that social frame and
orienting to other things that people
are looking at you're gonna have trouble
making sense out of the world so you
minimize distractions isolate the
relevant information and go from the
parts to the whole we're doing a B and C
because we want you to avoid having
dental caries but explain very clearly
for the child with Aspergers who's often
very verbal be explicit putting things
into words will be very helpful to them
and this is my last slide before I turn
it over to my colleague challenges for
oral healthcare vary with age and the
very developmental level and there's
wide variations in both there's a major
major major importance of starting early
getting the child familiar with the
dentist the dental office and procedures
for many parents this process is so
stressful
they end up avoiding dental care as
adolescents and young adults you end up
with major problems often eating general
anesthesia for the simplest of dental
procedures and with that I'm turning it
over to dr. Papo who's gonna be careful
not to step in the courts all right so
like dr. volkmar said my name's ben
pople i'm gonna hopefully teach you guys
a few things about autism and dentistry
so kind of the goals of our our talk
here I really want to emphasize a team
approach it's going to take everybody to
get involved to have success I also want
to identify some potential challenges
that you could commonly face and then
share realistic techniques for getting
getting to where you want to go there's
the pH or dental office particularly
moves really quickly so a lot of really
advanced and intricate ways to manage
and improve behavior might not be
realistic so keep that in mind as we go
through here so we're going to talk
about dentistry we always want to talk
about prevention first because dental
decay is something that that we can
prevent
and if we can prevent decay and keep a
healthy mouth we avoid a lot of
potential problems that we could face
down the road so a little bit about the
general population and caries it's the
most crop dental caries the most common
chronic childhood disease in the United
States right now it's more than 16
million kids suffering from untreated
tooth decay so it's a really big problem
whether the children have special needs
or not kids myth miss over 50 million
hours of school a year and parents miss
over 25 million work hours a year so
it's a really really big problem and on
top of that children with special
healthcare needs and children from
low-income families are hit the hardest
so they tend to have the most dental
problems the first step in kind of
addressing this overarching problem of
dental decay is establishing a dental
home is something the American Dental
Association and the American pediatric
Dental Association really emphasize so a
dental home is a continuous relationship
between the patient and the provider so
it's not a place you go just when you
have a problem which happens a lot in a
dental setting we want to see kids
within six months of the first tooth and
no later than the first year and really
the earlier the better there's no time
to early for a parent to bring a child
to a dentist if if not just to teach the
parent how to take care of the teeth so
this also includes the dentist referring
patients to the right right places if
they can't treat their needs as a
general or pediatric dentist so it's
it's a one-stop shop really and then
early intervention is really important
along the lines of the dental home like
I said we want establish the dental home
no later than twelve months and
especially with children with autism
dental emergencies are a bad time for
new experiences
unfortunately we can we can make the
dental office as fun as as possible but
there are certain things in the office
that are always going to be there I saw
a four year old kid who had a really bad
experience before they saw me and I said
this is totally different and they
walked in the room they said that lights
the same that chairs the same and
there's not a lot I can do about that
and it's really hard obstacle to
overcome so on
we really want to have the first visit
be as early as possible we want it to be
a good simple visit and we want to teach
high good hygiene skills earlier in life
so it's a lot easier to teach an infant
how to brush and get in that fight and
get a fight with an older kid who might
be more like The Incredible Hulk over
there so I'm a little biased because I'm
a pediatric dentist but I think
pediatric dental office is the best
place for any child with special
healthcare needs
very few general dentists work with
special needs patients are comfortable
working with special needs patients
there's a study by Casa Massimo who said
that showed that less than 10 percent of
general dentists are comfortable working
with special needs so we see a lot of
families that have been to like four or
five different dental offices before
they make it to us so a pediatric dental
office really is the best place to start
and pediatric dentists it's been an
extra two years in residency basically
learning how to deal with behavior
management challenges and work with
special needs patients and the the APD
actually has a find a dentist website
that all you have to do is put in your
your zip code and they'll tell you what
pediatric dentists are in the area so
it's it's a really helpful resource some
parents might say that um that's great
pediatric dentistry sounds good but my
child has a lot of adult needs you know
they might need a denture or implants or
a crown and bridge and those are things
that pediatric dentists don't typically
do but pediatric dentists did go to
dental school so we're trained to do
that
and if we're not comfortable doing that
we will we should know where to send the
child to a provider who's comfortable
treating somebody with special needs
so the pediatric dentist is still a
really good place to start to avoid that
bouncing around that can happen and of
the million-dollar question
do children with autism experience more
dental decay and the answer is we're not
really sure there's a fuel it reviews
out there so I'm of them say more decay
some of them say less and some of them
say we're not really sure and but what
we do know is that dental visits and
dental hygiene at home are a lot tougher
in children with autism
and they do experience a lot more high
caries risk characteristics which means
things that lead to dental decay so this
is I could probably have 10 slides of
the different high caries
characteristics that come up but these
are the ones that are most frequent so
poor coordination detrimental oral
behaviors like hitting the face and
stuff like that can happen medications
are a big thing they can cause dry mouth
gingival overgrowth especially with the
anti epileptic drugs other medical
diagnoses low cognitive level use of
sweets for behavior management that
happens a lot especially like really
sticky foods can be a really huge
problem for us so what can we do to get
to get a dental bit a cavity for things
need to come together basically
so the tooth we want to keep that for as
long as possible so the time we want
that to be as long as possible we can't
really mess with those variables but the
diet and the bacteria levels in the
mouth we have control over so a child
who's more low functioning and might not
be purchasing their own food or have
access to food choices we can keep the
diet really low and form edible
carbohydrates that lead to dental decay
so even if we're brushing even if we're
not able to brush very well we're
keeping the stuff out of there that can
lead to cavities and then a higher
functioning kid we can teach them to
brush really effectively and and do well
with their oral hygiene and prevent
decay that way if we have less control
over the diet so if we can eliminate one
of these we can really go a long way in
preventing problems of course preventing
decay especially in this population and
really with any child caregiver
involvement is crucial so the caregiver
establishes the routine I've never seen
it but it'd be really great if to hear
about a child with autism whose routine
is disrupted because they're not allowed
to brush I don't think we'd see a whole
lot of decay right
caregivers can make a real hygiene the
priority they determine the diet like we
already kind of covered and the level of
severity of disease kind of
Herrmann's the level of the caregivers
involvement which you know makes sense
sometimes
the teeth kind of fall by the wayside in
terms of healthcare so memoria the the
autism the caregivers comfort goes down
oral health practices diminish and the
child general oral health tends to be a
lot worse so one thing that can help
kind of one of these quick fixes is a
visual aid this study this study used I
think it was about twenty kids and all
they did was this is an abbreviated
version of the visual aid they just post
it up in the bathroom and the parents
walk through this with the steps of
brushing and it increased their oral
hygiene visible plaque was reduced and
the most important thing for me is the
majority of parents stuck with the
program after the study ended so it was
easy enough for them to keep working at
it when we're talking about prevention
fluorides always going to be a big thing
so the ad a unreservedly endorses
fluoride in water and in toothpaste it's
safe its effective and it's necessary
there can be you know different ideas
about fluoride and how it relates to
autism but as far as I know there's no
indication that it affects autism in any
way so on the commercials you'll see
this big glob of toothpaste and that is
not what we want they do that to some
more toothpaste if they're under two
years old we want to use a smear of
toothpaste and if they're over two we
want to use the pea-sized amount the
reason for that is they could swallow
some and if they do swallow it you can
lead to stomachaches and chronic
gastritis so but if it's used the way it
should be there shouldn't be any
problems so it's like I said we had this
list of the most common high caries risk
characteristics we can eliminate half of
them just with diet management and good
oral hygiene so it can be we can really
do a lot and then helpful products for
at home three sided toothbrush they sell
it on Amazon it's like five bucks it can
be really really helpful for pain
- they have a tough time getting to all
the surfaces and it's not really
realistic you can just pop that on top
of the tooth brush back and forth and it
gets all the surfaces at once so it can
really simplify brushing it's it's may
or may not be as effective as the
traditional tooth book tooth brush but
it can definitely help floss aids they
make it a lot easier and then you can
use a make a mouth prop out of anything
so if you put together some popsicle
sticks with some tape you can pop it in
one side of the mouth to keep them open
and then brush on the other side so we
talked about prevention now we're going
to talk about getting ready for a dental
visit things to keep in mind like dr.
Volcom already said every patient with
autism is unique and strategies that
might be really effective with one
patient might crash and burn with
another and that doesn't mean you should
throw them out
so Jennifer Marshall at a University of
Washington had some really great studies
that talked about parental
questionnaires and what what kind of
predictors are out there for for
cooperation so she asked questions like
can the child sit for a haircut is the
child toilet trained do they brush at
home and who does the brushing what's
the level of language development and
what kind of classroom setting the child
is in if a child can sit for a haircut
it was 100% predictor that they're not
going to sit for dental treatment so
it's a really good question to ask on a
pre visit survey that you could email
out to patients and they could send it
back on the parent end you can ask the
parents how they think the appointment
will go these parents know their kids
her study showed that like 90 foot there
were 95% correct about whether an
initial exam would go well and in these
other categories it was over 85 percent
so the parents are a good resource and I
think we can kind of forget that
especially with with kids with a lot of
health other health needs so it's also
important to ask parents about advanced
behavior management techniques we put
kids in first
and pupusas when we do dentistry
sometimes and it
important to ask about dental materials
and any concerns they might have about
what's going in their child's mouth
because it is an issue in this patient
population and if it if nothing else it
just gets the parents thinking about it
so it's not like a new thing right when
they walk into the office controversial
materials robert rata put an article out
in giada that the Journal of American
Dental Association that kind of goes
over all the kind of the most common
hot-button issues and their mercury
fluoride gluten casein antibiotics as a
dentist it's it's really hard for me to
keep up with every little thing that's
in a dental materials
if a parents concerned about these
things I can send the the names of the
products I'm going to use to the parents
and they can decide for themselves if
it's if it's something that they're
comfortable using so appointment
practice is really really good even as
simple as using the bed as a dental
chair at home the patient can get used
to just somebody coming over the top
with instruments in their hands that can
be a big problem for some kids some
school-based some school and
center-based programs have dental chairs
on-site and had pretty elaborate setups
so practicing with that is can really
help too and then practicing like an
escape so a hand raising signal might be
really good and to prevent like an
aggressive kind of outburst or running
out of the room and then the behaviors
that they learn that they're gonna learn
at home can can translate into success
in the dental setting it's not like the
things that happen at home happen at
home and then we get to the dental chair
and everything's totally different it
can push over
so of course visual aids again this is
just an example a short example of what
we use in our clinic you know it just
walks through what they're going to see
as they go to each step in the
appointment and then on the bottom here
you can see just we have a mirror I
don't know they're going to see the
light and Mickey Mouse's in the room
just things to kind of make everything
more familiar
and then of course we want to set
realistic goals so if we go through
these questionnaires and we talked to
the parents and it sounds like it's
going to be a really difficult
appointment don't don't try to make it
too hard on yourself
make it as easy as possible so it the
first visit especially can be really
good and you can work up more difficult
things so now we move on to the dental
visit
so ABA is a term that that comes up in
the dental journals a little bit I know
it steps a little bit more into dr.
Volkow Mars world but uh so ABA is
observing the relationship between the
environment and behavior to modify
socially significant behaviors through
opera and classical conditioning and
we're going to use you can use
reinforcement or punishment and we're
just adding and removing stimuli in the
case of a dental setting there's always
already enough kind of negative
punishment related stimuli so we tend is
I think it's better to stay away from
that but reinforcement is good so like
they can practice at home they get a
sticker every 20 seconds they sit still
or sit with their mouth open or negative
reinforcement will will drill and count
to five while we're drilling and if we
stay still for five seconds then we stop
and get a break even if it's like a
microsecond break and we go back to work
it can be really really effective so of
course we want to be prepared
dr. volt more kind of touched on that we
want to minimize waiting room time as
much as possible so a way to do that
practically in a dental office setting
is to have that patient the first
patient of the session whether it's in
the morning or whether it's in the
afternoon so the waiting rooms a little
more quiet and there's no appointments
that could run long and keep the child
out there and then it's really important
that the staff knows what's going on and
has everything in the room on hand so we
don't have to do much waiting while
we're in the treatment room but once
they're in the room we don't want to
rush we want to take our time we want to
go as slow as it needs as we need to go
to keep everything calm and get
everything done and then we want to keep
consistent so same treatment room every
time
I'm same treatment team every time the
same order of treatment it's not always
possible in our clinic we have 12
residents in two locations and then
assistants wrote it rotating through all
of that so we it doesn't always work out
that way but the more consistent you can
keep it the better
these sensitization visits can be really
helpful and that means we're going to
slowly introduce treatment over a series
of visits and a lot of private practice
dentists would probably look at this and
say there's no way it just it's not
practical from a business standpoint
because we're gonna do five appointments
just to get one exam done but if you use
this this kind of model we can we can
really only use the dentist the fourth
or maybe just the fifth appointment and
we can recognize in the first three
visits that maybe this isn't working out
maybe the the desensitization visits
aren't doing anything and you can
abandon that before the dentist wastes
time in their office schedule so it can
be done if you want to do it so verbal
communication hi dr. Baltimore touched
on we want to be friendly we want to be
direct and repetitive we want to avoid
being super polite that doesn't mean
yell at the patient it means like dr.
volkmar said don't with a normal
unaffected like four-year-old girl I
might say hey come come back here with
me let's go look at your teeth will
count them all will you please sit in
the chair it might be too much it might
be better to just say I sit here you
know you don't have to be mean but
avoiding the really complicated speeches
is better and if the family uses any
familiar terms at home it'd be nice to
know about those so you can help
communicate with the patient a little
better and then positively reinforce
good behaviors immediately so the
stickers or the breaks frequent breaks
can be really helpful behavior shaping
is another thing I like to do if a
patient doesn't even want to sit in the
chair
maybe we just sit on the edge of the
chair and then when that's comfortable
we'll move a couple inches and get a
little closer to where we need to be and
in those situations it might be better
that once the patient gets in the chair
that's all we do for the day because
that might that might take a lot of work
you know and it's on its own and then in
in pediatric dentistry we use a lot of
different behavior management strategies
that are kind of ingrained in us and
sometimes they're just not effective so
it's important for a dentist to know
that that sometimes it just might not
work face masks or something that we
kind of used the eye tracking research
to kind of determine it might help to
keep your face uncovered we know
children with autism tend to focus on
the mouth more than they focus on the
eyes or upper face to gather information
so the first thing we do when we're in a
dental visit is we we get a face mask
and put it over our mouth which probably
isn't helping anything so there's
there's not really a lot of research out
there to support that but it just kind
of makes sense that a face shield that
keeps the mouth open might help some
common sensory obstacles that we see
during the dental visit and some
solutions so movement can be a problem
the dental chair doesn't actually
doesn't really recline gracefully so it
might be better to just keep it reclined
I have the child hop in the chair while
it's already down so it's just one more
thing to eliminate taste smells and
texture are always going to be a problem
so unscented or unflavored products if
you can find them are really effective
sometimes just doing two or three teeth
the time and wiping the material away
can help and then I actually sell
payslips prophy angles so the little
wheel the Venice brushes your teeth with
can come with grit on it so we don't
have to use the pace at all it can be
really really helpful sounds can be a
big issue if the if the suction is
causing problems you can just throw Gaza
in there it's it's not as easy or we
would just use gauze all the time but
but it's helpful noise-canceling
headphones can can be good and then
electric dental hand pieces are a lot
more quiet than the traditional
air-driven so you don't get that whistle
sound sites are a problem
the dental light is notorious sunglasses
can be good and I actually sell dental
mirrors with the light built into the
handle so if the light's a problem you
can just stick the light in the mouth
and it can help and then touch so we we
have to touch the patient but frequent
visits can hopefully make us a little
more familiar and then you know only
touching two or three teeth at a time
not you know going for it x-rays can be
a big problem nobody likes getting
x-rays whether they have autism or not I
haven't met anybody who likes it so
panoramic x-ray so the x-ray that goes
around your head can actually take the
same x-rays that we take with the bite
in the mouth they're not quite as
diagnostic but they can give you a
really good idea of what's going on
we'll talk about a little later we take
a lot of kids with autism to the
operating room and especially with older
kids we don't always know if it's going
to be an eight-hour case and there's a
cavity on every tooth or if it's just a
cleaning so if we can take x-rays we
might be able to figure out all right
these guys all have really good oral
health and they're really short cases
and we can stack up like five or six
cleanings and if we can do that versus
plan a whole day for one child and then
we have nothing to do all day it can
really help our schedule out and get to
the kids you need to help physical
restraint is something we have to talk
about studies out there recommend or say
that kids with autism are put in a
purpose like almost half the time
they're there in the dental office and
some providers can justify that with
deep pressure theory but the pressure
theory doesn't have anything to do with
putting your hands in somebody's mouth
so it's it's important to keep that in
mind
it is effective in it you know obviously
you know a lot better job getting a
dental exam done if you're not worried
about getting hit or the patient's
squirming around but it needs to be
talked about with a parent ahead of time
and if a parent's not comfortable with
their child being wrapped which is
totally understandable but you think the
weight would help the lead apron from
the x-ray can be used as an alternative
so if deep pressure theories the the
reason it's working the lead apron or
work just as well and then we want to
learn from each visit we want to think
about what the problem behavior was from
the visit we want to think about what's
what's maintaining that problem behavior
and then what we can do to to eliminate
that problem behavior and replace it
with something that's a little more
acceptable and of course take detailed
notes think about what worked and what
didn't work it's always going to be the
freshest in your mind right after it
happens and it's important to use each
encounter as an opportunity to try new
things so all the stuff you tried didn't
work at all last visit you can try it
again at the next visit and you can
fine-tune the approaches that might have
worked and then help helpful products
for the dental visit kind of a recap the
dental mirror with the light on the
handle the textured prophy angles the
lead apron and sunglasses so kind of
closing it out
former pharmacological management's
sedation dentistry is something
pediatric dentists tend to do a lot a
lot of the outcomes are unpredictable
even with unaffected kids it's kind of a
provider to provider how comfortable
they are how deep they're comfortable
taking patients into sedation a wide
range of medications are used and
there's a wide range of results from
studies where they're like we tried
everything nothing worked and some
studies will say we had incredible
success with every patient it's kind of
all over the place
previous sedation experience can give a
lot of insight so it's not uncommon for
children with autism to have been
sedated in the past so asking about that
can really help common drugs that
pediatric dentists or
surgeons den Elana and Suzi ologist
might use diazepam ketamine midazolam
hydroxyzine Emmett paradeen and all
kinds of combinations and dosage dosages
and routes of administration it could be
oral it could be in her nasal it could
be IV it's it's kind of whatever the
clinician feels is right for them and
for that particular patient and then
finally the operating room it's a lot of
kids with autism end up in operating
room for their dental treatment there's
no real way around that in a lot of
situations the the dental decay gets
worse before the behavior gets better so
we have to go the good news is is that
most parents find this acceptable they
get it they've seen how difficult it is
to treat that child in the dental
setting and it's just easier sometimes
to go to the or and at our clinic we
take kids every three years if we can't
do an exam and if we can't take x-rays
so a patient who goes to the operating
room there's no reason to abandon all
the things we've just talked about the
goal should still be to work towards a
good exam in the clinic and x-rays
because like we talked about before if
we have an idea of what we're getting
into it'll help us schedule and it'll
help the patient avoid oor trips that
they might not need so the summary of
teamwork is really important we need the
parents and all the caregivers and the
dentist to all be involved if that
doesn't happen we don't really have very
very good odds and we want to be
proactive and identifying challenges
parents shouldn't be afraid to say I
think this is going to be an issue or I
think this might work and the dentist
shouldn't be scared to try new things
either and then we want to implement the
new techniques that we've we've learned
at home and in the clinic
you